the cool thing about these is they're
related to each other okay Walter
tension is actually a shortcut for us
it's actually a shortcut or an
abbreviation if you like so let get it
right down underneath your table I'd
like you to write down the symptoms
multiplication is an abbreviation that's
a long word let's spell it out shall we
a b b are the multiplication is the
cremation the question is what's it
apprec what is it an abbreviation all
now we usually use abbreviations in
language don't we instead of saying I am
we say okay so you're saving a whole
syllable okay so you're taking something
logging in you're riding it into short
form but everyone knows when you hear
someone say I am they're good that you
mean yeah right but we have other kinds
of abbreviations some special radiations
of corny acronyms because each letter
said for a homework right because
Cherryville technology high school is a
bit of a mouthful and it's a bit of it
takes a long time to time as well so
that's why we use abbreviations okay
what's multiplying what is it
abbreviated what is it shortening yeah
we're gonna finish the sentence okay so
Lisa space in the air well on the next
line here right cut me out five times
thinks that's a little bit new five
times three what's that short for Sophie
heads up before you tell me how what is
five times three if I were writing down
not just the actual number what's it
short for five times three
yes
so wait we've got the language it's
expanding yeah but what does that mean
five groups of three okay which is kind
of why we take time so that I can write
five groups of three watch I'll write
them here's one okay I'm done
there's my five groups of three okay
this is what five times three means
there are three and I've got five of
them okay but this is long and a painter
right and very repetitive but you know
what this is going to be just like you
know what these are going to be okay
which is why we write them in this short
form okay so what's the multiplication
in an abbreviation of its abbreviation
of addition isn't it if you want to add
lots and lots of things that are the
same you can use multiplication instead
it's much more efficient okay
mathematicians as you as if you haven't
already learned you will learn in the
next six years
Maithili two designers Tori ously and
lazy people which sounds like sounds
unusual like mess is hard work actually
mathematicians are always looking for
shortcuts for how to do things but the
whole branch is a mess about how to take
all things and make them short okay so
should relation of addition know I'm
gonna keep exploring inside either P
final times three that's how I write it
how about
now how would I write it before you told
me the answer how would I write it
present good now it is a picture of the
pier so there's still warm
ok now he's the important thing I want
us to see okay you all you all been
wanting to tell me this for a long time
what is it actually equal to the first
one particularly 15 what's the second
one equal also 15 now what you see is
that the order here when we switch it
around it doesn't change the final
answer does change what it looks like in
the middle but you get the same result
the same product at the end ok now this
is a really important property we give
it a name because it's so important to
the scene it's another long word like
all these any takers
it's yeah now these are all calculations
and that is a group of word that starts
at sea but I will give something a
little more specific I'll give you the
word because it is a bit unusual
he's the sentence of my kid right
underneath this multiplication is and
we'll put this next word in a minor
capital so if you've gotten on the Kama
you can do that and multiplication is
what we call commutator okay well that's
a weird word which means that
if you switch the numbers around if you
do them in a different order five times
three to three to five the order doesn't
change the answer the order of the
numbers
okay now that's a really important idea
to get by the way commutative we have
another word that is very very similar
to that maybe your parents do this if
they work in the city does anyone know
the other English word that's very
similar this it's actually always there
its entirety this word when you stick an
e on the end commute right don't your
parents talk about commuting using it's
about changing location so they say hard
to commute to work I have to go into the
city after commute by train or commute
by bus right how do you see there's a
relationship there it's about changing a
position right that's what community is
it's like you're going to commute from
here to there and so same thing with
these numbers they're kind of community
if you want and it doesn't change the
answer now multiplication is commuter I
might put a little a little see here not
for copyrights but for commutated
multiplication is not the only
commutative operation there's another
one which one is the other one where you
can change the other and it doesn't
matter
yeah it's addition isn't it this one's
also commutator
because you know all of these phases
okay they're the same that's a bit
boring isn't it
three plus four is the same as 4 plus 3
I can walk around with no order no
problems still 7
subtraction and division can you see why
they are not commutative right we were
thinking about subtraction yesterday
whoa okay so for instance if you do 5
minus 3 what's that equal to just
quickly that's 2 but if we switch them
around and change the order which I hope
we did a bit of doing your homework
yesterday that's equal to not - its
equal to negative 2 ok so the answer is
not the same when you switch it around
and division we get to give a little
later but also the autumn N and that
really matters ok ok so what we go just
commutator maybe you can addition as
well now let me just quickly illustrate
this for you I'm gonna go with my own 5
times 3 and 3 times 5 ok how can we draw
this
well I suppose you could view it like
this let's do it like so I've got a
block of 3 there's a group of 3 okay now
what Fineman my last one there we cut we
count them up go ahead and do it one two
three four five six seven 12 13 14 15
that's a relief
okay you always want to make sure you
get your right answer at the end so that
is five times three how would I do it
differently
to demonstrate this how could I do it
how many do I have here across the top
I've got five so what I'm gonna do
instead is to draw a cross like so right
and there's gonna be five
three or five is what you prefer he's my
last one so you want to throw that in
different colors also you can
distinguish them
there's my same two equations if you
like one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen okay and that's three
lots of 5 3 times 5 3 x 5 ok and if you
like really these are two ways of
looking at the same thing aren't they if
I were to take a grid tell like taking
the screen and slicing it up different
ways just slice that very quick slice of
horizontally sangria question oh you
sure yeah so this green I can chop it up
one way or I can chop it up another way
but it's still the same green right it's
just like if you had a block of
chocolate and you divide it up into
words or you divide up into columns
you're still gonna have the same block
breaking up in a different way I don't
imagine can give you more chocolate
which is unfortunate but that's reality